so as bad as the July 3rd speech at
Mount Rushmore was for Donald Trump and
certainly the July 3rd speech contained
way more verbal glitches it was what
we're calling benzodiazepine Trump I
previously referred to it as downer
Trump sometimes we say ambien Trump the
July 4th speech on the lawn of the White
House was absolutely terrifying and
Donald Trump actually taking some of the
same ideas from July 3rd about we're
fighting Marxists here in the United
States
and and actually building on them in an
even more cartoonish and dystopian way
Trump's big messages recycled things
from the previous night were essentially
we have agitators and looters and
anarchists and Marxists that we are
fighting against we are now in the
process of defeating the radical left
the Marxists the anarchists the
agitators the looters and people who in
many instances have absolutely no clue
what they are doing what Marxists are we
fighting like please find me an actual
Marxist with any power whatsoever that
Donald Trump is fighting against I
tweeted yesterday preparing for this
segment can someone send me the name of
a specific powerful Marxist that Trump
is fighting against and someone sent me
an article about some black lives matter
a person is a quote trained Marxist I
had never heard of her and with all due
respect it's not someone who is in any
way wielding any amount of power that
would be comparable to what Donald Trump
has with the bully pulpit like if that's
the woman that Trump is fighting when he
says we are fighting Marxists then it's
a really weird fight for Trump to
actually have to wage now there were
also no shortages of glitches here's
Donald Trump struggling to say sweepings
has Swift's whiffing sift Swift
completely incoherent again this was
tweeted widely with people saying wait
people are saying Biden has dementia how
do you explain this
take a look they delivered a swift and
swim
and you know that sweeping it was swift
and it was sweeping like nobody's ever
seen anything happened just barely able
to get the words out white knuckling the
lectern engaged in a battle to the death
with his own tongue all really really
wacky now eventually he got to the point
in his force of a fourth of July speech
where he just lists historical figures
he did this July third and Mount
Rushmore already played that for you
here is Donald Trump his list listing
historical figures on his July 4th
speech and the crowd sort of actually
does start clapping I guess it was the
the most exciting thing that Trump said
George Washington Thomas Jefferson Betsy
Ross Alexander Hamilton Benjamin
Franklin John Adams James Madison Dolly
Madison the great Frederick Douglas how
weak are these applause lines right just
listing people for the crowd to clap and
it went on like that for a while I don't
want to subject you to the entire thing
another really strange applause line was
when Trump mentioned that the virus came
from China people just starting to clap
at the mention of that fact take a look
but there and then we got hit by the
virus that came from China
and we've made a lot of progress our
strategy is moving along well now I
don't at this point want to spend a ton
of time on the China stuff the real
message here is what a deranged fourth
of July speech but it is interesting how
in these China discussions it's never
mentioned that China was the source of
the virus for every country like if if
the virus originated in China Spain was
dealing with a virus that came from
China Italy dealt with a virus that came
from China New Zealand dealt with a
virus that came from China so the fact
that it came from China doesn't change
that just about every other country
dealt with the virus better than the
United States
okay Brazil is a disaster India and
Russia are not doing well I've heard of
some small countries that are not doing
well but the fact that it came from
China how does that even bear applause
and of course it has no bearing on the
fact that Trump completely failed in
terms of his dealing with the virus but
I don't want to focus too much under the
virus today but again Donald Trump
during his fourth of July speech goes
into the only reason we have so many
cases is because we have so much testing
likewise testing there were no tests for
a new virus but now we have tested
almost 40 million people by so doing we
show cases 99% of which are totally
harmless results that no other country
can show because no other country is
testing that we have not in terms of the
numbers or in terms of the quality
remember we've got a fact check it Trump
says 99% of cases aren't harmful that's
not true seems that the death rate is
about 1% but that doesn't mean 99% are
harmful
many more people are ending up in the
hospital we still have questions about
the long-term health effect even in
people who do recover so that's wrong
our testing per capita is still just
26th in the world our deaths per capita
are the ninth highest in the world out
of more than 200 countries
and territories that have cases so the
narrative continues to be completely
untrue but his followers love it and
they fall for it and then sort of to
wrap up the 4th of July speech just one
more clip here's Trump saying that the
media slanders him when they accurately
report that something he said was either
racist or xenophobic these are great
heroes let me also say a word to those
in the media who falsely and
consistently label their opponents as
racists who condemn patriotic citizens
who offer a clear and truthful defense
of American unity that's what our people
are doing we want a clear and faithful
defense of American history and we want
unity when you level these false charges
you not only slander me you not only
slander the American people but you
slander generations of heroes who gave
their lives for America this is just
hilariously and laughably nonsensical
when you call Trump out for doing
something racist you are slandering the
troops that served in the military in
all of American history is what Trump is
saying when you point out Trump did
something racist you are disrespecting
people who served in World War two and
Vietnam like how does that even compute
and that's what Trump is trying to
convince people of and sadly it works i
tweeted yesterday that this will work on
some of his followers a bunch of people
responded saying David you're wrong this
will work on most of his followers from
the rally at least it seemed that that
did resonate with people when the media
calls Trump racist
they are disrespecting the troops if you
convince people of that in Orwellian
fashion it's almost more reminiscent of
the Testaments and oh my god what is
Margaret Atwood's first
before the testament that the handmade
sale it's more reminiscent of the type
of propaganda you see depicted by
Margaret Atwood in a Handmaid's Tale and
the Testaments and it's working on his
followers which is why even though the
polls look good for Joe Biden I know
it's gonna be an uphill battle going
into November we'll have continued
coverage of this on the David Pakman
show instagram page at david pakman show
for pictures of me at the beach which
are triggering men and women alike for
very different reasons follow me on
instagram at david pakman I'm half
kidding but I'm not kidding that we'll
be right back in two minutes